I always always uh when we when we talk
about things on the podcast I always get
uncomfortable when none of us have a
differing opinion about some things I'm
like [__] is this a collective Health
take because I'm like we could be
completely out of touch on this thing
right yeah I'm like what if we're just
wrong like I thought you were gonna say
I thought you're gonna say what if we
just like what if we're falling off
we're not arguing anymore you know also
kind of like agreeing with each other is
it [__] boring when we just all agree
none of us have any devil Advocates to
play like no because you know we still
get to have like a conversation about
like how we collectively feel about it
right and yeah if if we decide to have a
collective L take on it then hey man at
least we're all living together I'm
having an L take with the boys whenever
I agree with Jerry and God I'm like man
I must be wrong I must be in the wrong
year it's like I'm in danger right now I
bet people on the all accounts are going
to vent about this episode they're gonna
be like why didn't they get me well well
we see it probably won't see it probably
not yeah yeah you know I always it's
always I always like that we get to talk
about certain things that are maybe more
serious or more deep on the podcast but
I always do worry I'm like man with
three guys who we live in our own little
circle yeah and we don't have enough
outside opinions sometimes that's why
it's a nice having guests on there as
well yeah yeah for sure the differing
opinions I mean we
I think we're pretty good though
covering bases yeah hopefully hopefully
touch touchwood touchwood yeah I mean I
I like I like to think that we all have
we all come from different backgrounds
we all have different opinions and
different ways of looking at the world I
think that's what also I like how I like
discussing things with you guys because
when I'm wrong I'm like they'll tell me
right don't tell me what if we just
leave you swimming the comments will get
him yeah before
like before trash days I didn't realize
how much of my life experiences and
perspective was just based around oh
it's just like a Southeast Asian thing
isn't it well hey yeah well you re you
you don't realize until you get grilled
online for every minute thing you say
yeah that oh [__] maybe I I thought some
things that were just wrong oh it wasn't
me thing
[__] I thought it was an everyone thing
God there are something that are just me
things I'm like please please be my
Heritage come on come on
we all think all the bread tastes the
same right fellow Southeast Asians right
General nobody is born knowing the
correct takes or whatever is deemed the
public opinion on a take and you just
have to learn it and we're gonna [__] up
and and you all [__] up at home probably
you probably just don't realize it
because nobody's grilling you every
goddamn second of the day analyzing your
opinions and what you meant by them well
that's the problem with uh social media
today right is that like there's that
especially with content creators there's
that expectation of like how did he she
not know about this thing that they
clearly weren't raised upon it's like
well [__] me man like it's almost like
I'm leaving a completely different life
to you genuine question
do you think there is kind of like how
can I word this
a rage economy going on for sure in
social media I mean everyone also wants
to have an opinion because in in our day
and age having an opinion on something
is the only currency that we have
socially like you just have to have a
take like that's everyone's thing now
yeah and of course because we've learned
that you want to get as many likes
whatever and we okay we've said this
before on the podcast before but like
it's it's to to have likes in any
direction you go hard in any in one way
or the other right I just feel there's
like there's no winning in a situation
like that uh especially if you have a
social media presence because it's like
in this day and age I feel you not
giving an opinion is still giving an
opinion you know it's that whole idea of
like it's it's like it's like okay so uh
what do you think about this particular
situation that everyone is having an
opinion on and if you don't want to get
involved which you know some people
choose not to that's fine then that
becomes a statement in and of itself why
don't you have an opinion on this and
then when you give an opinion it doesn't
matter which way you go there's going to
be someone angry I mean I do I do kind
of agree that inaction and having no
kind of thoughts on it is also kind of
uh an action in itself yeah because
you've chosen not to get involved and
it's like what does that say about you
yeah if you don't want to get involved
but also it's totally understandable if
you're just fatigued by a lot of stuff
that you're like dude I don't this issue
I don't [__] care about this issue I
have other issues that I'm see that is a
level-headed person's way of thinking
yeah yeah right unfortunately on Twitter
if you genuinely go on twitter.com to
decide how your opinions are formed then
I think you're already going to be
having weird ass thoughts and a really
bizarre and extreme opinions I think I
think it's very important to make your
own mind up yeah absolutely like have
have you guys like noticed um as time's
gone on
um you know we talked about how
attention span has gone shorter because
of the internet have you noticed just in
general because of just some things you
see online you just end up getting like
a bit angrier more often than you used
to just because of some stupid article
or some stupid opinion yeah definitely I
I feel like that like especially in the
last couple of months I feel like every
day I open up [__] Twitter I just I
start off with just rolling my eyes
being like oh [__] what now yeah like
what's the new thing that everyone's
angry about I'm like I'm so sick of this
[__] can I just have a day where I just
go on to Twitter and all I have to worry
about is the next hentai pick I see it's
like can we have that back please like
can people just chill yeah I don't know
because I feel like it's really easy to
get into this like self-destructive Loop
of like oh this thing this thing like
you know there are different tiers of
things because sometimes you just see a
stupid tweet and you're like [__] why am
I getting annoyed so that this tweet has
20 000 likes yeah why why am I
disinvested in someone's dumbass opinion
yeah I just like I I hated that feeling
so I've like I've been trying to go on
Twitter and just you know social media
less but like I kind of realized that I
just I just ended up like it it felt
like one my brain chemistry was changing
because I was getting used to the fact
that I would just be getting emotionally
invested in things that I really
shouldn't be emotionally invested in
general different things that would have
never ever mattered to me in any other
circumstance or any other situation in
my life for some reason now I'm invested
in this one situation right and I don't
know why yeah and I feel like because
it's thrown in your face now right like
there's almost no escape from it unless
you consciously choose to not I feel
like I have the opposite where I'm I
just kind of disassociate and don't care
for any of these situations right I I
didn't really pay my attention to to a
lot of issues recently people get angry
because it felt so insignificant and so
small um you know and then also when you
see that getting angry has the opposite
affection where it was like oh everyone
getting angry
it completely defeated the point because
they they made everyone angry and then
everyone had an opinion and then it made
it even worse yeah it's like okay so was
was all of that for nothing yeah was all
of that to to for the for your main
argument and main point to just be
undone like it's like why when it seems
that getting angry or getting worked up
about stuff just leads to even worse
consequences
I feel like and it's like it's like
ma'am I feel like we just have to pick
our battles smarter online I just I I
feel like I don't know if I'm usually
going to use the right terms I I feel
like there is like a subconscious
addiction to it I love it I think people
love getting angry I I feel like with
the way with the way the internet's gone
I feel like subconsciously people are
looking not like maybe not like
consciously looking but subconsciously
it's it's like whenever there's
something they can
grab onto to get angry about or like to
like look at this thing and be like look
how dumb this thing is online yeah
um I don't there's there's this
subconscious thing in your brain that
goes yes you should you should get
involved in this you should have an
opinion on this one way or the other and
I feel I feel like the internet and
social media has trained our brains to
to do that yeah yeah I don't like maybe
this is just me growing up my generation
but I don't know if this is the way
things worked in previous generations
you know people would just let people I
mean I think the way it used to be and
the way it kind of I I think I
appreciate more and more is that you
kind of just pick the battles you're
passionate about yeah cause that speaks
to you yeah maybe for whatever reason
that is and I still try and do that you
know obviously if there's if you're I
think there's a difference between
um supporting an argument and actively
getting involved in it yeah uh you know
and I think that's that's a really
important distinction to make and
something that gets lost a lot where I
think a lot of people perceive inaction
as a lack of uh kind of support in any
way where it's like well I in some way I
kind of disagree where it's like if if
you on on like say on online or
something like let's say
I don't know how to how to word this
correctly uh without getting my whole
entire career destroyed
like it's it's like if you're not
actively doing stuff to
um
like further a cause or you're not
trying to like raise money or spread
awareness does that mean that you don't
support something and it's like I don't
I don't think that means you don't
support it I think it just means that
maybe that's one of the things you
didn't choose to spend your energy on
yeah there's only so many battles you
can take like at the end of the day
you've got to go to work you've got to
go to school you got to do [__] and you
can't go home every single day and be
like all right what's the new thing
what's the new battle what am I what am
I uh what am I getting passionate about
today it's like I feel that as human
beings we just we were just meant to
survive and then maybe if you have the
time and if something is really
passionate maybe it affects you directly
or maybe affects a loved one then maybe
you get more involved with it and I
think it's like expecting everyone else
to feel as passionately as you do 24 7.
causes a lot of friction like and I
think it's it's that kind of stuff
that's frustrating and it leads to
people who maybe are in support of stuff
to get really frustrated and really
tired because other people who support
it but way more passionately like why
aren't you doing as much as me why
aren't you saying as much yeah yeah and
I think that's a really that's been a
really uh tough thing to deal with
because on the internet now it's so much
more accessible and so much more uh so
much more uh so much easier to to say
those thoughts to someone and I I feel
like a big thing is that I don't know if
I explained that even that could have
been gibberish yeah I don't know that
made sense because I I feel like a big
thing is that it's never been easier to
feel like you can be involved you can
make a difference in something even if
doing a tweet or doing a Facebook post
is like the the entirety of what you can
do you still feel like you're
contributing in some minute way to
something and I feel like that feeling
of
that that emotion of feeling like you
can have an effect direct effect on
something or someone has just caused
this kind of environment yeah uh because
okay
Theory Theory okay
I feel like I feel like there is a
reason why they're like
a video trend has gotten really popular
recently and it's the video trend of how
ex YouTuber fell from fame or how this
person Fell From Grace right or how this
person right I I don't like those videos
too much but I will admit I'm [__]
addicted to them okay there is something
about those videos where I'm like I
shouldn't watch this but my something my
brain's like you should
if the presentation is terrible even if
the quality video is so bad I think the
information in it is quite valuable in a
weird way
in a way that just kind of hacks your
brain but I but it's but it's so crappy
these types of videos are the True Crime
for YouTubers
like we are the white girls and those
are the True Crimes I agree I agree
because okay you're right you know you
know what I'm saying because like I feel
like okay very I I feel there is a
subconscious part of your brain that is
like I want to feel
it's I want to feel better than someone
today I want to feel like my life is
going better than someone else's today
and there's a part of you that's like
preparing for the worst yeah yeah it's
like learning by example and there's a
party that's like prepared okay this is
what I need to not do to [__] up yeah
and so even though there is probably
nothing in those videos that or like
maybe one video will be useful but like
watching 15 of those videos there's you
know you can't really guard anything
just while those 15 videos you know the
story there's some Minecraft Youtuber
they gross the fame really quickly and
then they fell off okay we know the
[__] story yeah
um but there is there is some part of
your brain that I think you watch those
videos because you are kind of
everyone's going through some hard
things in life and we want to know how
to make our lives better and you know
even though it's not a pleasant thing
sometimes seeing someone yeah make
yourself feel better yeah that that
feeling of like ah it wasn't me yeah
yeah yeah I don't know why we would like
this yeah I don't know why I would like
this but there is some part of you
that's like oh I'm so glad that wasn't
me yeah and you know it sucks it sucks
because it could be us it could be us
but you're like you and I I know that
but some part of me is like
no I totally get that like you could be
like the most like wholesome supportive
nice person that's like you know
open-hearted to like every person every
difference and everything but like you
know sometimes yeah like negativity or
viewing negativity sometimes reinforces
self-positivity and it's like that's
just how we are as people unfortunately
yeah one one thing that I uh I had a I
had thought about
I don't know why it stuck with me a lot
um uh there was this um this was a
charity event where uh you know some
celebrities had gotten involved and um
like big big big celebrities yeah and um
I was having a conversation with someone
who uh was working for the charity and
they were talking about oh how they
invited this other celebrity but they
said no because they're doing uh another
charity or something uh and I was like
oh that's weird why wouldn't they want
to like help both and they were like oh
well it's like in that in that sense
it's like you you have to pick your
battles like if you it's only so many
times that you can ask
um the audience or the people who are
paying attention to you to give money to
a cause yeah because you you know you've
got a few ask them one time then you ask
them again a week later you're like all
right well well dude I just gave money
like what do you you know pick the
battle here like pick the right course
and maybe think of like how it is how I
could extrapolate that kind of thought
to social media and how I how people
treat that in general it's like yeah
people got pick their battles as well
like you you can't always be there for
everything yeah people you know people
have to pick whatever personal priority
they decide to pick right I feel it's
very unfair to like criticize that
unless it's for like a really really
just like objectively unethical reason
right yeah but you know in the case with
like your example right it's like well
[__] I mean it's easier said than done
if if everyone had the mentality of
right of like oh I could just do both or
I could just do all of these then we
wouldn't need charities in the first
place you know like everyone would just
be well off right yeah everyone would
just be giving money to one another but
unfortunately that it doesn't work like
that like you you have to at the end of
the day some people sometimes just have
to prioritize what they need to
prioritize and those priorities might be
different from the next person yeah but
that's that's that's just how they are
like you can't I feel it's very unfair
to like push your own self-priorities
onto someone else especially if they
live in you know completely different
circumstances or completely different
lives right it's like yeah it's it's I
don't know I've I've that that's what
always irked me and especially when it
comes to like you know having an opinion
online about anything right it's like
you know maybe their priority is to not
get involved yeah like that's that
doesn't mean they're any less of a
person just because they're not getting
involved that's just their priority and
unfortunately there's nothing you can
really do or say to like change that I
guess yeah I don't know it's it's it's
tough I I don't know what I'm saying
it's like you have a lot of thoughts
that feel cohesive but explaining them
is so tough yeah yeah it is it is
um I'm just I know that a lot of people
come to the podcast because we don't
talk about a lot of political issues I
think it's also because we're [__]
terrible at talking about it yeah uh we
can barely talk about our opinions on
food yeah video games and I'm like uh
I'm gonna make the conscious decision to
not talk about this because I do not
trust my own self to articulate a
problem
let alone let alone a serious problem
I'm not articulating that in any way
there's people who can do it much better
than we do that's for sure yeah it's
tough it's tough the world feels really
rough right now yeah I think it's hard
to to stay positive and not get angry
about stuff I mean there's a lot of
stuff that is worth getting angry about
right now yes
um so yeah pick your battles pick your
battles hopefully uh hopefully things
change for the better and hopefully
you're not watching uh how trash taste
fell off uh in another three years it'll
probably happen at some point it'll
happen everything's got to fall off at
some point at some point so I just hope
it's well edited yeah if it does happen
yeah you know make it look nice at least